hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master sooner Berg hands and drain
you so I'm going to go with the default
opening I'm not quite sure what is
rapper twice to be honest seems no it's
not the news though get a queen's gambit
declined exchange didn't didn't know
what that Heath employs this variation
h6 okay it's this is this one of those
lines where you go g5 okay it seems it
isn't so this is ir k h6 is a useful
move now because after castle screen to
be one it's normally quite interesting
winning a temp or what there is no
temple now I still like the idea though
to play it it's not as powerful as it
usually is but still why not I am so he
wants to meet place see five years if I
go b5 he wants to go see fire so we
should be six those kind of ideas
interesting can try to reroute them this
is 96 maybe I think I'm going to do this
right now before he is even better
prepared 45
the structures generally believed to be
quite okay for black let's see I don't
know if a four a five if this is
actually helping me I'm going to put
this to deform and this is a problem and
I did not want to trade this bishop or I
allow him to trade it and now this is
probably going to happen hmm okay
yeah it's not not that great
maybe night f5 or Bishop f5 could be an
idea I have to be aware that night see
494 and quite sensible option C at times
currently nights before i'm winning upon
so it's not working yet but he has those
outposts yeah this is the simple
solution just take it I wonder if GTX is
actually an interesting move that covers
important important squares it just
makes my king look a little bit strange
but okay I mean it's not like he's
checkmating me right away I also thought
that Bishop to f5 as an interesting idea
trying to catch em into trading it's not
clear however that this does have any
relevance okay so what am I going to do
probably just okay I cannot really
double I can push the egg horn okay yeah
yes this check and maybe a queen h4 but
I don't think that this is more than
some sort of repetition Bishop f5 was
interesting when she might take and play
night c4 I wasn't sure that this is
doing me any favor
check yeah i was thinking just up to g2
i know he can repeat it but i'm not so
much in love with my position that i
feel i have to avoid the repetition at
all costs of course he might go rupee
eight or something along these lines
rookie a droopy five okay so seem it
seems that he is going for this
possibility ok so i'm going to grab them
and now see what happens night f5 he's
got the check so it's not losing any
material straight away
I thought that this would actually be
quite good maybe I'm missing stuff
like 96 the idea I thought that this
would be good maybe he can shake on he's
got an ID move coming possible I can i
th fire or something like that yeah very
very unclear to me the situation so
rookie 5 is not possible currently but I
wonder if he has some other way of
harassing me answer very much possible
lucky night whatever they hit 92 95 did
these moves and he can always check me
Nigel stuff stuff like that but I don't
I don't think it works I often have
games against him where we both spend
some time and at the end did some crazy
time scramble I think we're a bit
similar in our approach to trying to
find at least good moves not necessarily
the best moves but good moves and Jack
might often that is just too much time
spent maybe can sacrifice on a
three-year that that's possible 93 pawn
takes rook takes that is a very annoying
position but king of one-time money
maybe this is better actually you know
like 92 okay that was crazy I didn't see
92 okay so what is this can I actually
play Bishop it will yet to keep
everything under control
94 m might be the problem and now it
probably will not make a draw I mean
maybe his position is just better that's
one thing but he also has lots more time
we can probably make a knot double
second ID three projects okay so you
might repeat now but I don't want to i
mean i would like to fight somehow okay
so he's fighting
now I'm ahead on the clock
check night 2 g-3 as an idea oh I didn't
see this move I asked between g6 a
stupid stuff check now it's made check
check damn it that I should've won that
on time I mean I probably mean I'm not
sure about the position around here i am
I probably winning but it's it's always
tricky against him so here Bishop b2
just just winced at taking out every
kind of tech tech check yeah of course I
didn't I didn't see not between
beforehand yeah this is basically I'm
ending it I still have 97 ideas to be
porn and he has got no attack but he had
a good position for sure at one point so
yeah this line it's certainly quite okay
for him I went for this immediately now
Luke c1 and now I think I'm already not
so happy with this that he gets Bishop
define and then the trade I mean I know
it worse but it's it's something that I
didn't like all that much what does the
computer wants to play no it actually
like sunshine for okay yeah this is a
post
also a repetition it's funny at the
engine gives this move this is a very
good idea actually it didn't didn't
cross my mind to just attack him I mean
blacks position actually sucks yeah oh
my god he cannot take yet since easy
check o mine and this is fantastic for
white actually something I mean it has
yet to do something like that and this
is just an attack for absolutely nothing
oh that was a really bad way of that I
totally did not see that yeah and here
he can win with rookie three okay I was
pretty fairly sure that there should
should be something and this is the is
the one okay so I cannot take check is
he's got this enormous check in it's
made check now and again check but he
played this one and I just lose ass
basically it loses the game because he
has absolutely no compensation for a
seven but I did not I did not see not be
too happening I was just thinking okay
bring the night over to g3 I didn't see
not be too and this turns turns the
table completely I should win on time
though I mean like it here even I'm
probably not even worse Queen Texas ok
I'm but ok that was a premium primo fast
and here i am just made quick moves i
can just take the Queen here by the way
okay wit it was just like move move move
and said I'm allowing the checkmate this
is some time
is what happens in those games that you
have some completely useless finish to
an otherwise interesting game ok guys
thanks for watching